but do you know what else it is
it's all the weird creepy sex stuff it
bothers people
target right now is selling weird
transgender stuff for pride month
including to kids
target is teaming up with
tomboy x the tomboy x collection
includes this is at target a major
retailer
chest binders chest binders is when
women put on
very restrictive
bras i guess to make it look like they
don't have breasts packing underwear
i don't know exactly what that is but i
think i have a feeling and yuck bras boy
shorts in sizes small through 4x as
every size that there is
they've got swimsuit styles
bustle reported binders and gender
affirming gender affirming swimsuits
which means gender denying swimsuits are
notoriously difficult to find
particularly in extended sizes this
accessible drop will make shopping for
everyday garments easier yes this is the
top issue in our country right now right
so we need to make sure that morbidly
obese sexual deviants can can put on
clothing that makes them play dress up
and pretend to be the opposite sex
that's that's what americans care about
that's a real dinner table issue
wouldn't you say no it's not it's not
and it's weird and not only is it weird
and kind of unusual and so therefore
people are resistant to it but it's
actually wrong they're pumping this kind
of propaganda into our kids as well kids
items in the target pride collection
include toddler teas that proclaim trans
rights or human rights and sure it's
emblazoned with pronouns
with a rainbow merchandise toddler books
that include buy buy binary and the
pronoun book this is just disgusting
this is just awful and we should pass
laws against it to stop target from
doing it
okay the the slogans of of the last 10
years of a kind of feckless squishy
conservatism would have said well you
know target's a private company and uh
if you don't want uh mega international
corporations transgendering your
children well then build your own target
you have absolutely no right to tell
target that they can't transgender your
kids yes we do we do have that right
target doesn't have some kind of
constitutional right to trans the kids
we the people do have the rights as a
political community to stop pervert
corporations from transgendering our
kids we do have that right we can say no
no weird transgender stuff for kids is
is illegal boom done
pass me that law where can i where can i
find that law
you know we did we did the dr fauci
public health protection pledge i just
floated this idea on my show that i said
i won't vote for a federal candidate in
2022 who doesn't promise to get rid of
dr fauci to zero out his his salary and
then it's spread like wildfire and a ton
of candidates and a ton of sitting
members of the congress signed on to it
and then all of a sudden dr fatchi went
away
kind of interesting timing not saying it
was directly responsible but i'm not
saying it wasn't either well okay let's
bring up the next bill the
stop pervert corporations from
transgendering our kids bill
it's not a violation of the first
amendment it's not a violation of the
emanations or the penumbras or anything
else we have the right to standards in
this country and we have a right to stop
these sick predators
perving on our kids and selling all
sorts of deviant stuff in our major
retailer stores it's just
this is not an
extreme view of mine okay this is a view
that would have been shared by 100 of
the population five years ago
three years ago
and it's a view that the majority of
americans continue to support today
okay this is how you explain the parents
movement in virginia that's how glenn
juncken got elected is because parents
didn't want weirdos transiting their
kids and filling their heads with racial
ideologies this is how you explain the
parents movement in florida
okay this is how you explain the the the
vast
the extreme popularity of this kind of
an issue
what is it
explain to me why why it's so wrong to
trans the kids explain to me why it's so
wrong to have this kind of public
religious worship of weird sexual
ideologies
i could explain to you why that is i
think a lot of you out there could
articulate in words why this stuff is so
wrong but you actually don't need to
and i think for the majority of parents
and the majority of americans who oppose
this stuff
maybe they can't articulate exactly why
it's it's so wrong to sell chest binders
and
and what is it un boxer packing packing
underwear and and bye bye binary books
to toddlers they might not be able to
articulate exactly why it's wrong in
precise philosophical terms but they
just know it's wrong it's called the
wisdom of repugnance and they're right
the late conservative philosopher roger
scrutiny said the job of the
conservative intellectual is to
articulate the sorts of things that
ordinary people know intuitively
okay and
ordinary regular old run-of-the-mill
people who are going about their lives
and their families and their business
and don't have time to focus on all the
creepy predations of political activists
all day long they just know it's wrong
we should run on it's just like abortion
well it's different than abortion there
are several issues in the substance but
the political effect is the same
the squishes and the establishmentarians
believe
that we shouldn't touch the trend don't
touch lgbt
cue transiting the toddlers don't touch
it it's a culture war issue just run on
the economy no stupid no one cares about
we care about the economy we care about
tax rates we even sort of care about
marginal tax rates but nowhere near as
much as we care about these creeps
transiting our kids run on that don't
run away from pro-life run on pro-life
it's a winning message don't run away
from this insane sexual revolution stuff
run on it this is a winning message
people care about their culture they
care about their standards and we have a
right
to
to a public culture that is sane
and that that does not
that does not encourage this kind of
bizarre behavior that is extremely
destructive to everyone that it touches
it is time for republicans to pounce
you know this is what happens every time
the libs do something wrong and then
conservatives criticize them for it
what is the headline in the newspaper
the headline is republicans pounce
liberals hold ritual human sacrifice and
that's not the headline the headline is
republicans pounce on
liberal religious display
republican they're always pouncing those
republicans they just pounce everywhere
i don't know something about our knees i
don't know we're so good at well guess
what now is the time to pounce in the
political arena on issues that are big
winners for all of us
[Music]
[Music]